El concepto de fundamentalismo está esencialmente ligado al
concepto de medición en mecánica cuántica
antes de que se desarrollara la mecánica cuántica
los científicos tenían el conocimiento general
de que si tienes un sistema que está
determinado en cierto estado
y realizas una medición, vas a obtener
un resultado muy bien definido
en mecánica cuántica eso ya no es así: puedes tener
un sistema que está en un estado perfectamente bien definido
y sin embargo, al realizar ciertas
mediciones, puedes obtener resultados aleatorios
así que para ilustrar ese concepto mejor
necesito introducir el concepto de superposición
la superposición es un concepto que no es intuitivo
se basa en que un sistema puede estar mostrando
varias combinaciones lineales de estados
de forma simultánea, y puedes imaginarlo
como, por ejemplo, una onda de radio que lleva
muchas frecuencias diferentes: no hay nada
extraño en eso desde el punto de vista humano
lo que le da el sabor cuántico a la superposición es el hecho
de medir el sistema
lo voy a ilustrar con un ejemplo
imagina que tienes un sistema de flechas
y preparas el sistema
de modo que todas las flechas apuntan a la izquierda
y luego vas y
le haces al sistema la pregunta: ¿estás arriba o abajo?
y como cada flecha que apunta a la izquierda puede
expresarse, describirse
como una combinación lineal de superposición entre
arriba y abajo, obtendrás
como resultado un cincuenta por ciento arriba
y un cincuenta por ciento abajo cuando le preguntas si está arriba
obtienes ese resultado del sistema
y luego puedes preparar con eso
un estado diferente del sistema donde la mitad
también apunta arriba y la otra mitad
apunta abajo, y le haces la misma pregunta
y obtienes el mismo resultado
son dos sistemas muy diferentes
y has perdido esa información
para siempre
¿cómo puedes determinar cuál es la diferencia?
los sistemas son muy diferentes
porque en el primer caso preparaste el sistema en
un estado puro de superposición, en el que
puedes hacerle al sistema una pregunta que te dé un resultado determinístico
no aleatorio, y esa pregunta es: ¿estás a la izquierda o a la derecha?
te va a decir cien por cien que está a la izquierda
en el segundo caso no hay ninguna pregunta que le puedas hacer
que te dé un cien por cien de certeza, porque es una mezcla
porque es una mezcla
así que si preguntas izquierda o derecha
va a ser aleatorio porque la mitad están arriba
y la otra mitad abajo; si preguntas arriba o abajo
lo mismo: va a ser un cincuenta por ciento
¿cómo se relaciona esto con la aleatoriedad cuántica?
puedes imaginar que es algo
similar a lanzar una moneda: va a ser cara o cruz
pero no es como lanzar una moneda en absoluto
porque cuando lanzas una moneda
la única razón por la que no sabes el resultado que vas a obtener
es porque no conoces
la energía con la que lanzaste la moneda, el momento angular
las condiciones ambientales de la sala
y demás; si conocieras todas esas
variables, podrías predecir si saldría cara o cruz
son variables ocultas para el observador
y durante muchos años los científicos pensaron que había
variables similares en mecánica cuántica que se
manifestarían como aleatoriedad
y no fue hasta el
trabajo seminal de John Bell en los años sesenta que se demostró
que ese no es el caso
y ahora todo físico
reconoce que no existe ninguna
teoría de variables ocultas que sea compatible con la mecánica cuántica
así que es completamente cierto que cuando mides un sistema
la naturaleza revela el resultado
no importa cuánto tiempo piense en eso, lo sigo
encontrando asombroso